you have the most
upscale podcast Studio I mean these
cameras on the wall yeah got a two-way
mirror over there who knows who's behind
that
whom or whose it's a jury of your peers
sitting behind that you ever do jury
duty I've tried but they uh always asked
me to leave really yeah and what if
you're what if you're the defendant and
you leave no you if you're the Divine
you have to stay that's it kind of
another bit with the straw
um have you done jury duty
um no I've tried many times yeah they
don't like it when a known person is on
the jury sometimes they think it's
distracting so you did jury or no I
tried several times in New York and L.A
all right
I love it I've been on a jury twice
really yeah once was a hungry the second
one was guilty and it was it's fun you
you get an hour and a half for lunch you
could leave at 4 30 you know get there
at 10 30. this is what they had in mind
when they set up our judicial system
with sona's comfort
and uh snack schedule
I ran into a cop once and I said Is it
true if you get a ticket
and you don't pay you say you want to go
to court the cops usually don't show up
especially on a holiday or close to a
holiday so when you get that DUI last
time you should have kept that in mind
what happened there did you have you
just had a a mental I think a synapse
snapped right there you went audible
yeah and that happens you should keep
getting laid next time
you always make fun of people's uh you
know inadequacies I am now this is
you're you're falling apart you're an
ATM on the fritz what's happening Kevin
are you having a rough day
you know I was driving over here and I
think I can't wait to see Conan
I've changed my mind about that I really
have
why is it that every time we come on
here it's just back and forth why can't
we just be like a marriage no yeah it's
not speaking of which uh your wife oh
right it's just I am so lucky I am so so
lucky she's so smart she's beautiful
funny beautiful talented talented she's
so supportive unlike some people I know
I know my wife never helps me out
oh is oh is that we were talking about
no
no we both married well you got to admit
we both did very well we married what do
we call it up uh we married up we both
married up yeah we're two uh guys that
no one would probably want to hang out
with for very long I'm sorry I'm
including myself do you think you're
insecure basically I'm serious right now
you think you're insecure how do I know
you're being serious you're you're a
shape-shifter I'm not stuttering
wow oh that's a good tell
basically I'm secure I think I have been
in my life I think less so now than I
was maybe earlier in my life you ever
watch a daredevil
I know the Disney plus I don't
you're the worst therapist wait a minute
let's let's see where I'm going here
yeah do you know why let's see what's
going on I haven't seen the Daredevil
okay on Disney plus just called
Daredevil okay sorry I haven't seen
daredevil on Disney plus that's like
saying uh the Superman yeah or the
Batman oh wait that's what they call the
Batman because they ran out of titles
anyway and let me add let me tell you
why I asked you about the Dirt Devil I
just started watching it my son got me
kind of hooked it's just Daredevil
Daredevil uh the TV show
is about a guy who was blinded as a
child but he has all the other senses
are like increased you know super senses
that's why uh when you ask me what was
it
anyway my sense he's able to tell if
somebody is nervous yeah or scared just
by listening he could hear the heart
rate and that's what I did before
whatever it was you said what it was to
me
this is a total disaster
you care about you I love it you
interrupt you take over never never
get lost
it's incredible but you haven't happened
yet I know you couldn't help me we have
been talking for about 20 minutes and I
defy you I defy our listeners to find
three consecutive minutes that means
anything that has any continuity
it builds to any conclusion
if you have been listening to me you
would find a lot of continuity but no
you're off on a rant about the Drone
about me stuttering about you know
continuity issues you're not listening
you're in your own little head
I'm gonna try you again why is this date
so important October 27th that's when
hiking with Kevin premieres yes yeah yes
all you wanted to get to what about
let's talk about you have this book oh
now you're talking my talk
you're quite a good artist and
um I think you did a uh series of really
fantastic did you see these sauna
they're really interesting I'm seeing
them amazing they're amazing uh you tell
stories you write these sort of essays
about all these people that you've
encountered in Show Business and these
are really fantastic Christopher Walken
you guys are so nice I'm sorry for what
happened before what I did yeah now that
I'm from you're happy when I'm promoting
your wares really iconic people in here
well since this is audible Conan is
looking at my new book that's coming out
October 25 Conan uh it's called I
exaggerate my brushes with Fame it's a
collection I started painting uh well
I've done multimedia started a couple
years ago and I've always loved to draw
you're actually in the front of us I saw
you're more of a sketch and yeah you
didn't you didn't uh
you didn't give me like a real portrait
no I didn't because I've seen a lot of
caricatures of you and I've been into
your office and there's so many
paintings I thought he won't even
appreciate this oh I would have but look
this is one you did of me in
1992. yeah so this is before I got the
Late Night show and you did this cat's
in the front yeah that is right here
Isn't that cool and there's another one
of you in there can you find it and I
remembered no I don't think there is no
it's in the front huh yeah it's like one
of those anyway um I've only seen one I
love to is that me right the page back
beautiful
woman oh no flip back back back okay
Jesus
no no I guess I'm wrong how about go
forward now no there's no other one of
me there's just that one all right now
go back again okay now go forward okay
stop it anyway so so let me you you
asked me I'm going to tell you I started
you know I've been an artist most of my
life you know I started doodling people
when I was a really young kid and then
when I got to SNL during the table read
I would sketch people in the margin of
the script that I wasn't in and I didn't
care about and uh whoever was sitting
across from me it could be Farley or
Dana so
and then I started sketching people on
airplanes you'll see some of those
sketches in the beginning it's got a lot
of exaggerate my brushes with Fame and
uh We've plugged that we've plugged the
book here's the cool thing about the
book Conan it's gonna make a great gift
because it comes out around the holidays
but check with your doctor so uh can I
see something Jonah and I'm gonna ask
Edward to jump in too have you guys
noticed that he's completely incoherent
when we're just trying to talk as normal
human beings but the minute he's
promoting something you are the most
eloquent speaker since Winston Churchill
suddenly you are this great Statesman
every thought nuanced uh and packed with
meaning the book also has an inverse
next to it next to the uh each painting
and they're little antidotes to kind of
relate to the person that I've drawn
it's called anecdotes you keep saying
antidotes anecdotes
antidotes anecdotes there's medicine in
there that's what I'm saying
and there's a story that relates my
history with that person my experience
um unless I don't know the person I.E
Freddie Mercury I.E meaning that is and
although if it's a Freddie Mercury type
I will just reminisce about being in a
garage band so you have people in here
you have obviously Gary Shandling who
you were very close to and you know
what's nice you reprinted your the euge
you gave for Gary I did which was uh
really beautiful and funny and touching
one of the best I've ever heard and so
it's uh nice that that's in here you've
got an amazing Howard Stern this
Christopher Walken oh yeah uh that one
jumped out painting is absolutely
fantastic uh he looks like a feral owl
but it looks like a troll doll almost
yeah you've got Schwarzenegger who of
course you worked with back in the day
with Hans and Franz yeah that's my
friend that is correct we wrote the
Hanson Franz uh movie it was a musical
yes I'm just reminding you of that there
are people who want to see that script
they people are asking for a table read
no I know I know we can't figure out who
owns it
did you know that we've actually looked
into it because
um Robert Smigel myself Dana and Kevin
in 1992
uh wrote a Hans and Franz musical uh
with Arnold Schwarzenegger in it and
then it it didn't get greenlit and soon
after that I was off to host the Late
Night show but that's where I know you
from
incredible
yeah I was I was kicking myself saying
where do I know this guy from
he looks so familiar
um you're right so it was a musical but
also you're forgetting to say that
Arnold Schwarzenegger was going to
co-produce it and star in it as well
yeah yeah
and then it never was made
and some people now are saying they want
the table read for the Hans and Franz
musical
um I have no memory I remember us I
think being on some lot
uh writing it together you kept coming
in and at the time you were only
drinking Health shakes
I think you came in every day and you
spent a lot of time mixing powders in a
giant like baby bottle really and then
you would sip out of them and you wore a
tracksuit uh and oh that's when I was
training for the Olympics that's right
yeah yeah
um and I never had a track suit in my
life you did you wore a tracksuit I
remember you were lying on the couch
with your shorts on or maybe their
briefs and you had no shirt on
I think you could sketched you I
sketched you
it's true it's true and I was worrying I
remember this I was wearing the locket
that Kate Winslet has in Titanic I
remember that really well that is true
as well remember and then we wanted to
put it in a safe and then you and I went
running through the ship together oh
yeah well an Irish music played
you um there has been a call for us to
do a table read for the Hansen France
musical I hope that happens someday but
I understand no one can figure out I
don't hey I don't know if anyone who
cares who owns it I think you have to
get the permission or something I don't
know what about making money from it are
we yeah well I would insist that we try
and make at least a couple hundred thou
you're all about cash are you I need
cash badly I've been to I made a I don't
I don't really I made some Bachelor some
bad people I don't really I'm not I'm
very comfortable where I am in life my
wife is from old crypto so
um you
uh you're such an ass